hablemos un poco sobre lo que podría
causar un cambio en las curvas de oferta
y demanda de una moneda aquí tenemos un
mercado de divisas para el yuan chino
por lo que aquí en el eje horizontal
tenemos la cantidad de joanes chinos y
en el eje vertical el precio del yuan en
términos de otra moneda en este caso en
términos del dólar estadounidense y
asociado con la curva de la oferta o su
1 y con la curva de demanda de su 1
tenemos el punto de equilibrio en la
intersección hemos hablado de esto en
otros vídeos llamemos a este punto es 1
este sería el precio de dólares por
johann digamos que es igual a 10
centavos de dólar por jean y luego
asociado con este punto tenemos la
cantidad de equilibrio curso 1 que es
una cierta cantidad de joanes que se
está intercambiando en el mercado en un
cierto periodo de tiempo esta gráfica o
modelo aplica para cualquier periodo de
tiempo una manera general de pensar en
que podría influir en la oferta y la
demanda
es pensar en quién podría ofrecer la
moneda y luego quién podría necesitar
esta moneda
entonces si estamos pensando en el
mercado del yuan chino la oferta va a
ser de las personas que poseen joanes
personas que poseen ioannis y la mayoría
de estas personas son las que se
encuentran en china es posible que haya
alguien en nueva york' que tenga una
cuenta en yuanes o que tenga yuanes en
su cartera pero la mayoría de estas
personas están dentro de china así que
la oferta está motivada en gran parte
por lo que pasa en china motivada por lo
que pasa en china y por otro lado si
pensamos en la demanda sucede lo
contrario estas son personas que por
alguna razón quieren convertir su moneda
en yuanes entonces son personas que
tienen otras monedas como dólares
estadounidenses es posible que alguien
en beijing tenga dólares o tenga una
cuenta en dólares pero en general la
demanda va a estar motivada por otros
países
entonces por ejemplo si pensamos en la
oferta que podría mover la oferta hacia
la derecha o que podría incrementar la
oferta mover la oferta hacia la derecha
significa que más chinos quieren vender
sus yuanes significa que quieren
convertir sus iones en otra moneda
digamos que en dólares estadounidenses
de modo que esto podría ser un
incremento en la demanda de bienes
servicios o activos extranjeros
en este caso podría ser un incremento en
la demanda de bienes servicios o activos
estadounidenses tal vez ellos quieran
tener activos estadounidenses porque
obtendrían un mejor rendimiento o tal
vez porque los consideran una inversión
más segura tal vez quieran enviar a sus
hijos a estudiar en escuelas
estadounidenses lo que sería un
incremento en la demanda de escuelas
estadounidenses para sus hijos lo que
sería un incremento en la demanda de un
servicio tal vez estén interesados en
comprar más automóviles estadounidenses
si hay un decremento en los aranceles de
automóviles podrían ser más baratos en
china de modo que podría haber un
incremento en la demanda de estos bienes
estadounidenses cualquiera de estas
cosas podría producir un cambio hacia la
derecha de la curva de oferta es decir
un incremento en la oferta que sería o
sub 2
y como resultado tendríamos un nuevo
tipo de cambio de equilibrio y sub-21
nueva cantidad de equilibrio que se está
intercambiando en el mercado
y fíjense que el precio de los yuanes ha
bajado porque en este caso la gente
demanda más bienes estadounidenses y por
supuesto si cambiamos las fechas aquí si
tenemos una demanda menor por los bienes
servicios y activos estadounidenses
entonces la curva de oferta se movería
hacia la izquierda y el yuan sería más
caro en términos de dólares y del lado
de la demanda funciona al contrario que
podría mover la curva de la demanda
hacia la derecha o incrementar la
demanda llamemos a esta curva de 3
supongamos que la curva de la oferta no
ha cambiado así que este punto sería e
sub 3 el yuan se ha vuelto más caro y
esto tiene sentido más gente lo está
demandando y ahora tenemos una cantidad
diferente llamemos a este punto q sub 30
que causaría que cambiará en ese sentido
la demanda del yuan sería mayor si
tenemos un incremento en la demanda de
bienes chinos desde el extranjero
demanda de bienes servicios o activo
chinos por extranjeros con dólares
entonces si tenemos un incremento en el
número de estadounidenses que tienen
dólares o cualquier persona que tenga
dólares y dicen podría obtener un mejor
rendimiento si invierto en china si
piensan que van a crecer más rápido
entonces convertirían sus dólares en
yuanes dirían quiero comprar yuanes con
mis dólares para poder participar en el
mercado de valores chino o comprar
acciones o de alguna manera comprar
algunos bienes raíces chinos o lo que
sea y obviamente si la demanda de bienes
servicios o activos chinos disminuye
entonces la curva se moverá para el lado
contrario hasta el próximo vídeo